Plastics you know about them you may not
love them but chances are you use them
every single day
by 2050 researchers estimate that there
will be more plastic in the ocean than
fish despite our best efforts only 9% of
all plastic we use winds up being
recycled and even worse plastic is
incredibly tough and durable and
researchers estimate that it can take
anywhere from five hundred to five
thousand years to fully breakdown it
leeches harmful chemical contaminants
into our oceans our soil our food our
water and into us so how did we wind up
with so much plastic waste well it's
simple plastic is cheap durable
adaptable and it's everywhere
but the good news is is there something
else that's cheap durable adaptable and
everywhere and my research shows it may
even be able to help us with our plastic
pollution problem I'm talking about
bacteria bacteria are microscopic living
beings invisible to the naked eye that
live everywhere and all sorts of diverse
and extreme environments from the human
gut to soiled skin to Vince in the ocean
floor reaching temperatures of 700
degrees Fahrenheit bacteria live
everywhere in all sorts of diverse and
extreme environments and as such they
have to get pretty creative with their
food sources there's also a lot of them
researchers estimate that there are
roughly 5 million trillion trillion
that's a five with 30 zeros after it
bacteria on the planet now considering
that we humans produce 300 million tons
of new plastic each year I'd say that
our plastic numbers
are looking pretty comparable to
bacterias so after noticing this and
after learning about all of the creative
ways that bacteria find food I started
to think could bacteria and plastic
polluted environments have figured out
how to use plastic for food well this is
the question that I decided to pursue a
couple years ago now fortunately for me
I'm from one of the most polluted cities
in America Houston Texas in my hometown
alone there are seven EPA designated
Superfund sites these are sites that are
so polluted that the government has
deemed their cleanup a national priority
so I decided to trek around to these
sites and collect soil samples teeming
with bacteria
I started toying with a protocol which
is fancy science talk for a recipe and
what I was trying to cook up was a
carbon-free media or a food free
environment an environment without the
usual carbons or food that bacteria like
us humans need to live now in this
environment I would provide my bacteria
with a sole carbon or food source I
would feed my bacteria polyethylene
terephthalate or PE t plastic PE T
plastic is the most widely produced
plastic in the world it's used in all
sorts of food and drink containers with
the most notorious example being plastic
water bottles of which we humans
currently go through at a rate of 1
million per minute so what I would be
doing is essentially putting my bacteria
on a forest diet of PE T plastic and
saying which if any might survive or
hopefully thrive C this type of
experiment would act as a screen for
bacteria that had adapted to their
plastic polluted environment and evolved
the incredibly cool ability to eat PE T
plastic and
using this screen I was able to find
some bacteria that had done just that
these bacteria had figured out how to
eat PE T plastic so how do these
bacteria do this well it's actually
pretty simple just as we humans digest
carbon or food and two chunks of sugar
that we then use for energy so to to my
bacteria my bacteria however have
figured out how to do this digestion
process two big tough durable PE T
plastic now to do this my bacteria use a
special version of what's called an
enzyme now enzymes are simply compounds
that exist in all living things there
are many different types of enzymes but
basically they make processes go forward
such as the digestion of food into
energy for instance we humans have an
enzyme called an amylase that helps us
digest complex Sturgess such as bread
into small chunks of sugar that we can
then use for energy now my bacteria have
a special enzyme called a lipase that
binds to big tough durable PE T plastic
and helps break it into small chunks of
sugar that my bacteria can then use for
energy so basically PE T plastic goes
from being a big tough long-lasting
pollutant to a tasty meal for my
bacteria sounds pretty cool right and I
think given the current scope of our
plastic pollution problem I think it
sounds pretty useful the statistics I
shared with you on just how much plastic
waste has accumulated on our planet
are daunting they're scary and I think
they highlight that while reducing
reusing and recycling are important they
alone are not going to be enough to
solve this problem and this is where I
think bacteria might be able to help us
out but I do understand why the concept
of bacterial help might make some people
nervous after all if plastic is
everywhere and these bacteria eat
plastic isn't there a risk of these
bacteria getting out in the environment
and wreaking havoc well the short answer
is no and I'll tell you why
these bacteria are already in the
environment the bacteria and my research
are not genetically modified Franken
bugs these are naturally occurring
bacteria that have simply adapted to
their plastic polluted environment and
evolved the incredibly gnarly ability to
eat PE T plastic so the process a
bacterial eating plastic is actually a
natural one but it's an incredibly slow
process and there remains a lot of work
to be done to figure out how to speed up
this process to a useful pace my
research is currently looking at ways of
doing this through a series of UV or
ultraviolet pre treatments which
basically means we blast PE t plastic
with sunlight we do this because
sunlight acts a bit like tenderizer on a
steak turning the big tough durable
bonds in PE T plastic a bit softer and a
bit easier for my bacteria to chew on
ultimately when my research hopes to do
is create an industrial scale contained
carbon free system similar to a compost
heap where these bacteria can thrive in
a contained system where their sole food
source is PE T plastic waste imagine it
one day being able to dispose of all of
your plastic waste in a bin at the curb
that you knew was bound for a dedicated
bacteria powered plastic waste facility
I think with some hard work this is an
achievable reality plastic eating
bacteria is not a cure-all but given the
current statistics it's clear that we
humans we could use a little help with
this problem because people we possess a
pressing problem of plastic
solution and bacteria might be a really
important part of the solution thank you
[Applause]